[Music]
hello street talkers and welcome back to
the channel
today is an interesting episode we have
dr simon stringer
who's a british mathematician who's
currently working at oxford university
in their
theoretical neuroscience and machine
learning departments
and it was a fascinating conversation
we're looking at the intersection
of neuroscience and machine learning now
current neural networks are incredibly
limited
they have no local processing they have
no kind of cyclical processing it's
always left to right
and they only have very basic encoding
of information
and the tldr of today's session is that
we're going to make the argument that
complex self-organized dynamics and
sensory representations
do not emerge from current neural
networks
now when you speak to go-fi people when
you speak to some some other advocates
of different
methods of achieving ai they tell you
that neural networks are just building a
taller tower
to get to the moon and we should be
looking at entirely different methods
but
one of the things that's really you know
been
impressed on me in today's conversation
is that there are
lots of other ways that we could extend
neural networks
certainly to be more biologically
plausible and to increase their fidelity
of encoding information
so importantly complex self-organized
dynamics and sensory representations
do not emerge what we're ultimately
interested in is the emergent behavior
which is only achievable if you simulate
the kind of dynamics that we have in our
own brain at a very low level
now some people believe that there are
sophisticated self-emergent kind of
dynamics in gpt-3 which make it a kind
of
artificial general intelligence i
disagree i think that the platform the
architecture and the training context of
gpt3
is just far too basic for these dynamics
to emerge
it's the information processing which is
important and that depends
on the neuronal dynamics now it's really
important to start looking at some
biologically inspired
designs for neural networks now one
thing to get curious about is this
concept of neural encoding
there are many different encoding
methods that have been described in the
neuroscience literature
things like rate coding which is as the
intensity of a stimulus increases the
frequency or rate of action potentials
or the spike firing
increases another method which uh simon
is a huge fan of
and has done a lot of work in in this
area is temporal encoding
precise spike timing or high frequency
firing rate dynamics
can be found to carry information and
what do we mean by carry information
it's a little bit like
you know you have frequency modulation
on the radio or
amplitude modulation so you have a
carrier wave
which is a synthoidal function and you
need to you need to modulate it to
encode information
that's what we're talking about here how
do you encode information
in the neuronal dynamics in the brain
there are some other methods which i
don't think are used in an artificial
context so things like population coding
which is where we represent stimuli by
using the joint activations of a number
of neurons and
sparse encoding i found this on
wikipedia as well where each item is
encoded by the strong activation of a
relatively small number of neurons
some of simon's early work was in rate
coding using
unsupervised competitive learning and
there were a couple of algorithms in
particular that he utilized
one was called trace learning which
works on the basis of the similarity of
signals in a contiguous fashion so kind
of
temporal contiguity if you like and
another one is continuous transformation
learning which i think simon actually
invented himself which is about learning
the spatial similarity of images over
time
now these methods are really really good
at learning invariant representations
which means you actually have
compositions of features at every
spatial scale in the hierarchy and
things like rotation
or location or scale and various
different other types of invariants
depending on the experience of the
learner
now the thing that simon's been really
interested in in recent years
is this temporal encoding this idea that
the temporal pattern of the encoding and
some kind of
emergent behavior or some complex
dynamics might emerge from this
temporal encoding that's where simon's
really interested
and there's actually an algorithm called
spike time dependent plasticity or sgdp
and he's been running simulations on
this and stdp
strengthens the connection during
learning if the presynaptic cell is
actually participating
in driving the postsynaptic cell and if
not then it gets decremented
so this is actually a variant of hebbian
learning
so you've probably heard of hebbian
learning mentioned a few times in the
literature
it means that cells fire together wire
together
so there's it it's kind of similar to
the kind of correspondence you see in
capsule networks for example it's all
about the correspondence of the inputs
triggering some kind of behavior so it's
about increasing the specialization of
every node in a network
and therefore increasing the fidelity of
the network and the fidelity bit's
really important because i think
um this kind of increase in fidelity
might actually improve the computational
profile
of this neural networks as well now what
are the principles of heavy and learning
well the first thing is a set of neurons
are all the same
except for some randomly distributed
synaptic weights
which therefore respond differently to a
given set of patterns
another principle is that there's a
limit imposed on the strength of each
neuron
and the final principle is that there
must be a mechanism that permits
neurons to compete for the right to
respond to a given subset of inputs
such that only one output neuron or only
one neuron per group
is active so on at the same time the
neuron that wins the competition is
called the winner
take all neuron now one of the really
important things we want to talk about
here is this concept of feature binding
and this is part of the self-organized
behavior that emerges
when you do this kind of spike
time-dependent plasticity
right so this self-organized behavior is
really really important when you have
this kind of temporal encoding
of information and neurons and one way
of describing this is a polychronisation
of neuronal groups or the temporal
dynamics of neuronal behavior
and when you study these dynamics as
they emerge
one thing that simon noticed right away
was these three neuron binding circuits
now this is the simplest kind of binding
circuit
actually there's a hierarchy of binding
circuits and the complexity
very quickly spirals out of control so
we couldn't even understand what's going
on here but
this is a really simple example of you
have two input neurons
that encode certain visual primitives
and
the encoding is actually a function of
the time
the temporal synchrony is actually
important in the encoding
of this information now an individual
neuron could participate in hundreds of
these polychronous neuronal groups
all at the same time you know so the
complexity just gets absolutely crazy
it's only the tip of the iceberg but
what's really exciting about this
is it gives you some idea of what
actually goes on in the brain
and why should we not be trying to make
neural networks replicate this
so there's a great example here of a
polychronous group representation of
bindings
and it's showing every single neuron id
as a function of time
and the binding relationships between
them and as you can imagine these very
complex dynamics emerge
and the neurons might be called again at
different points in time
representing different features at
different levels of the visual hierarchy
this is absolutely fantastic and i think
that these complex temporal hierarchical
dynamics encode a robust set of
primitives
and better represent the semantic
richness of our own experience
so i think one of the reasons why we
don't have the robustness in the current
neural network architectures is
we are not given the fidelity that we
would get if we had these complex
binding circuits and self-emergent
behaviors
what we need to understand with
artificial general intelligence is that
we will never understand the dynamics
that emerge it's an emergent phenomenon
and our ability to introspect and reason
and understand
what's happening will be limited it will
be extremely limited
another really interesting comment that
simon made is that psychologists and
philosophers
have long regarded feature binding as
the foundation of consciousness in the
brain
so coming back to hebbian theory we were
talking about that a minute ago
the idea there is that it increases the
specialization of every node in the
network and the fidelity of the network
overall
and this feature binding thing that
we've just been talking about it's a
really important part of
achieving robust object recognition and
that also means generalization
so this is a system which can provide an
alphabet of hierarchical primitives
and then encode novel objects and
recognize those objects including
from novel viewpoints so incorporating
that
in variance to various different
viewpoints and transformations
another thing is causality plays into
this as well so when you have this
hierarchical organization of
visual primitives if you like the rich
semantic information can be fed
you know from the motor areas and and
the visual areas in our brain
into the prefrontal cortex where we can
learn causal relations in the world
anyway i really hope you enjoy the
session today i learned so much because
i basically don't know anything about
neuroscience so
i feel like a complete school boy here
and it was fascinating to get an insight
in into this world
i actually think that many of the things
that we're discussing here today
will be the kind of things that we'll
have in our neural network models
in the next five to ten years so you can
think of this as being like a real
um you know quantum leap into the future
anyway
peace out wow we're getting professional
here as you know we're super interested
in
any parallels we can draw between the
world of artificial neural networks and
the kind of work that you're doing but
we'd love to talk about all the work
that you're doing in your lab
without any further ado let's kick off
welcome back to the machine learning
street talk youtube channel and podcast
with my two compadres mit phd dr keith
duggar
and janik lightspeed culture now today
we have an incredibly special guest
dr simon stringer simon obtained his phd
in mathematical state space control
theory
and has been a senior research fellow at
oxford university for over 27 years
simon is the director of the oxford
center for theoretical neuroscience and
artificial intelligence
which is based within the oxford
university department of experimental
psychology
dr stringer's laboratory houses a team
of theoreticians
who are developing computer models of a
range of different aspects of brain
function
this covers vision spatial processing
motor function
language and consciousness in particular
how the primate visual system learns to
make sense of complex natural scenes
simon's lab is investigating the neural
and synaptic dynamics
that underpin brain function an
important matter here
is the feature binding problem which
concerns how the visual system
represents the hierarchical
relationships
between features the visual system must
represent
hierarchical binding relations across
the entire visual field
at every spatial scale and level in the
hierarchy of visual primitives
there are different high-level
topologies of bindings in synaptic
connectivity
but crucially simon focuses in on the
polychronization or the spiking neuronal
dynamics in time
simon's team have noticed a timing
dependent plasticity
an emergence of polychronisation through
successive layers of the neural network
repeating spatiotemporal patterns in
response to specific visual stimuli
in what simon calls the polychronous
neuronal group
representing lower and higher level
visual features
now artificial neural networks also have
a built-in inductive prior
which encourages the hierarchical
organization of concepts
with vision models it starts to diverge
from the anthropocentric conception
because the data is presented to us in a
regularly sampled grid
on a planar manifold and the useful
inductive priors such as the
convolutional neural networks
start to exploit symmetries and patterns
in this very contrived and artificial
domain
so i really hope we can draw some
conceptual relations between
how a computer vision model works in
artificial neural networks
and neurons in actual meat space
anyway dr stringer it's an absolute
honor to have you on the show thank you
it's my pleasure to join you here today
really is my background is straight
mathematics my undergraduate degree was
in mathematics my phd was in
control systems actually working with
british gas developing observers for
detecting leaks and gas networks
after that i moved into computational
aerodynamics at oxford
then i spent some time in mathematical
epidemiology 1997 i moved into
theoretical neuroscience and i moved
across from engineering mathematics
into theoretical neuroscience because it
really is self-evident
that the brain can do many things that
today's machines can't
and there'll be many areas where
machines can beat the brain but there's
still
a lot of tasks where the brain is able
to make sense of its world
and act with a sort of lifelike adaptive
behavior that machines have not yet been
able to replicate
so the the approach i take to
understanding brain function is a
complex systems perspective
so a complex system is defined as a
system of interacting elements
whose systems level behavior emerges
through the interactions between those
elements
and once you adopt that perspective then
it means we have to look at the low
level biology
to really to see what's important the
low-level biology
which would contribute and shape the
emergent systems level dynamics that we
call cognition
and so that's the approach of my
laboratory so we pay very close
attention to the biology
now engineers often tell me well we
don't want to be bound constrained by
the biology i said no no the biology is
a signpost it's telling you where the
really interesting things
lie and so we take that long-term
perspective and it is long-term
which can make it difficult raising
funding for this kind of research
because it's not jammed today
um you know it's not as if we can sort
of um if i wanted to
to uh to to raise money easily i just
offered to
build a mobile robot to deliver pizzas
in greenwich and and it wouldn't be a
problem
but you know to get funding for really
long-term research where the
applications are years ahead
is quite tough but nevertheless this is
our ambition and what we're signed up
for
i love the way you you you pose that as
or set the framing that
look biology is a source of inspiration
for where all the interesting things lie
be or
potentially interesting things lie
because it's kind of had this
billions of years to evolve systems that
work well and kind of this low energy
low energy domain and we've often been
wondering you know
so we stripped away all these features
of neurons to get down to kind of like
like let's say some of the classical
digital neurons that we've been working
with
have we lost features that are actually
useful computationally and i think your
work
you know points directly in that thank
you very much for saying that keith
indeed the problem really we all we all
have this
we all we all say we're inspired by the
brain and
but then we end up with convolutional
neural networks and
the problem is we look at the brain it
looks like an awfully tang awful tangled
mess of complexity
an indecipherable tangled mess of
complexity and then we have to
reel back to something manageable
conceptually um but certainly
uh the sort of networks used by
engineers today they
really do bear very little relationship
to what's to the sort of dynamics which
are actually taking place in the brain
um so so my lab at oxford is really
focused on building what called
biologically
realistic models so there are rules to
the game
uh so for example plasticity is a local
process that uh
so to adapt the connections between
neurons we use locally available
biological quantities which might be the
firing rates or possibly
the timings of action potentials and
other local quantities
again engineers will say we don't want
to be bound by this but it's not it's
not it's not a constraint it's it's a
signpost
it's this is the direction of travel if
we really want to solve problems as deep
as consciousness itself
really um so so
uh in terms of the sorts of early
problems
my lab looked at we were looking at
obviously there was a focus on vision
uh so one of the early problems is how
might your visual system learn to
recognize an object from different
angles
very standard problem viewing variant
object recognition but we're not we're
not
going to do this using a form of
supervised learning as in a cnn we're
going to use unsupervised learning
because
where our brains work we don't see
labels over everything in the world one
of the most amazing things about the
brain is it just learns to make sense of
all this complexity
on its own so we used uh models
uh which uh which exploit unsupervised
learning um
uh specifically competitive neural
networks for example
so a hierarchical series of competitive
neural networks where we expose these
networks to lots of images whatever
those images are
faces dogs cats whatever and we look to
see
what the neurons learn to represent at
different stages of the hierarchy
and there are specific learning
mechanisms which
are which will only operate in these
kinds of networks which look like
these uh biologically broader learning
mechanisms
that are able to operate within the
context of an unsupervised competitive
neural network but will not
operate in a cnn in a supervised cnn
and so immediately and we just we were
investigating these sorts of learning
mechanisms for example known as
continuous transformation learning which
is something i i discovered
as a young postdoc and trace learning
these are these are unsupervised
learning mechanisms
um which the network can exploit to
learn transforming variant object
recognition and these are some of the
early work we did so these are really
biologically motivated architectures
with the hope that it sets us on a path
for even greater things
uh later on um now you've you've kicked
off talking about some of our research
on spiking neural networks
so a spike in your network is uh really
in the brain real neurons
use electrical pulses brief electrical
pulses called action potentials or
spikes to communicate with each other
this is how they communicate and indeed
very interestingly over the last
10 15 years neurophysiologists have
found that the connections between cells
the synaptic connections
are actually the way they're modified
through learning through sensory
experience
is critically dependent on the relative
timings of those electrical pulses
so that's telling you something
important as theoreticians ask on
neuroscientists we we've wondered how
important the spiking dynamics are
and certainly if you take a complex
systems perspective yes you would
suspect
these observed features of of of
cortical dynamics are important
to the emergence of the of the
representations themselves the visual
representations
and spatial processing of behavior and
so on um
so you're you're alluding to our work on
the feature binding problem
so the feature binding problem is
described by different authors in
different ways
and the reason people describe the
binding problem different ways because
people haven't really understood what it
is because
really to understand feature binding you
have to look at what's happening at the
lowest level
at the level of neural interactions you
know these things are rather ineffable
at a high level to really understand
what's going on you need to look at a
low level
now previously people thought about
feature binding is well i see a car
and i see all these features like edges
and corners and handles which are part
of that cup they should we bound to the
car
and so people who are thinking about
spiking your networks
spiking dynamics how could we exploit
spike in dynamics we're thinking okay
well let's imagine all the features
which are making up an object like a car
those neurons representing those
different species
features maybe they emit their spikes at
the same time
so in other words they're synchronizing
their spikes that was the classic
picture but if you really think about it
what does that really buy you and does
that really accord with the richness
of the semantic missions of our own
visual experience and psychologists have
known
for a long time that actually the
phenomenology of
primate vision is hierarchical in nature
so we see that this feature
is part of that larger feature and that
feature is part of that larger feature
and so on
and that mirrors what you see in terms
of the architecture of the visual cortex
which consists of a series of layers
a hierarchy of layers of neurons um
starting at cortical area v1
and onwards where neurons and successive
layers learn to represent
ever more complex and larger visual
primitives in the world
which provide an alphabet to encode any
new object
so really feature binding you should
really think about as being hierarchical
in nature
and that's really quite a different
perspective on what feature binding
actually is it's a much richer
perspective
it rewind back to the earlier viewpoint
that you look at any image you look at
your visual brain decomposes it into
several discrete object regions
again it doesn't begin to match the the
semantic richness of my own visual
experience
no if you think about the architecture
of um
say hierarch on your network like a
series of competitive layers or a cnn
we have a hierarchy of neuronal layers
where neurons
are reaching threshold in a traditional
network they're reaching threshold
they fire when that neuron fires it
tells you oh somewhere there's a cat
and that's all you know you know
somewhere there's a tail somewhere
there's a whisker
so the neurons can carry information
which can be measured
about features in the world different
spatial scales but those sorts of what
we call rate coded networks where you're
not modeling the actual spike in
dynamics don't keep a record of which
inputs are driving a particular
high-level feature new one
they simply reach threshold and fire and
in other in other words
these sorts of networks are leaking away
all that critical information about
horror combining relations between
features
and you know as a young as a young
postdoc we sit around looking at our
early vision models which are not
spiking and we'd all
want these things to be conscious and
you know operate like the brain we had
that sort of aspiration ambition
but we all have this niggling feeling
that something deep is missing in these
networks
and indeed uh once you think about the
this notion of needing to preserve
information about the hierarchical
relations between features of different
spatial scales
in the hierarchy of layers then you
realize that's really critically
important information for beginning to
make sense
of some complex natural scene and indeed
beyond that is probably critically
important to just basic object
recognition in the first place
and so we're familiar today with the
problem adversarial noise in convolution
neural networks
where one of these networks you'd give
it a tiny amount of image noise
imperceptible to human beings and
suddenly the network thinks the school
bus is an ostrich um
you know and i'm i'm sure that sort of
lack of robustness is well first of all
it tells you it's not operating like the
human visual
system certainly not mine and and it's
probably
i would suggest that hierarchical
feature binding and preserving that
information is probably relevant to that
problem there are other factors involved
which i can talk about
but certainly hierarchical feature
binding is part of it could we just take
a tiny pause
because i feel that you've you've opened
so many doors
in what you've just said and i feel like
we're kind of holding all the doors and
we need to close them one at a time
um so one thing is what you're talking
about here sounds like an efficient
encoding scheme right there's an
information theoretical aspect to it
because if you can
compare that to traditional neural
networks they they only do
feed forward they don't do any local
processing they certainly don't do any
any time-based encoding or anything like
that but it doesn't seem
entirely obvious to me how this kind of
time-based or rate coding mechanism
could give you the kind of spatial
invariance that you were talking about
so what's happening in our spike in your
network so about the turn of the
millennium
i think as a chap called marcus
diesemann he showed the emergence of
synchrony
in a series of layers of spiking neurons
and that that was a nature paper that
had a big
impact a lot of people talking about it
because a lot of people think about
synchrony
as a way to solving the binding problem
but in those simulations
either the axonal delays were set to
zero or they're set to the same value
and you know all of us running those
sorts of spiking outward simulations at
the time did the same thing we would
because in the brain the axonal delays
between neurons there there's quite a
distribution of them
you know up to you know for anywhere
from zero up to maybe
tens of milliseconds and so you can
imagine in one of these spike in your
networks if you put in those sorts of
distributions
of delays you would tend to well you
would disturb the synchrony
that might emerge and so you know in
early days
and if you look on our website you'll
see early papers on spikey nets where we
were trying to exploit synchrony we want
synchrony to emerge in the networks and
so
essentially we've cheated we've taken
out those pesky accidental delays
because they're going to disturb the
synchrony and it was a wrong thing to do
because synchrony really buys you
nothing
so what we've what we've done is in the
very first steps was to
put realistic distributions of action on
delays into these networks so we'd have
a hierarchy of spiking neurons
there are four key characteristics we
needed to incorporate into these spiky
nets to get a way forward to solving
horrible feature binding
so first of all we need the top-down
connections which everyone leaves out
indeed a lot of theoretical
neuroscientists would leave the top-down
connections out of their simulations
because no one had
any really good ideas why they were
there people were thinking in terms of
attention you're looking for your keys
there's a activity key activity or
prefrontal cortex which is feeding down
to visual areas
stimulating visual feature neurons that
might be used in code keys helping those
keys to pop out of a visual scene
and of course you know that sort of
attention is a real effect in the brain
but anyone who knows anything about
unsupervised competitive learning would
expect that those top-down connections
are playing critical role during the
self-self-organizational process itself
during early learning indeed one of my
colleagues who remained nameless
would run simulations where he'd have
learning on the bottom up connections
he'd fix all the weights and then put in
the top-down connections afterwards
using the bottom-up connection weights
yeah really missing the real
really interesting stuff about these
top-down connections that they could be
driving
the self-organizational process itself
and producing representations visual
representations which can't be produced
any other way
so top-down connections turn out to be
very important spike in dynamics of
course and sddp
and then the axonal transmission delays
so
this is what happens if we incorporate
some transmission delays
when we train the network on such a
network a hierarchical network on
many different object shapes we see and
i'll describe the most
basic expression of the concept
so the most basic expression concept is
what we call a three neuron binding
circuit
so let's say i'm going to have to to
illustrate this with my hands now
so let's say we have a neuron an early
layer representing a vertical bar
and a neuron in a high layer
representing a letter t
now sometimes that vertical bar is part
of t but on other occasions it could be
part of a letter p
or some other letter these sorts of
feature neurons could just
develop through unsupervised competitive
learning if we were to train the network
on lots of alphabetic letters
now in these spiking nets with these
top-down lateral and bottom-up
connections act on delays
what we see is the emergence of lots of
these three neuron binding circuits
where these
these two neurons the lower level
feature neuron and the high level
feature neuron
are then projecting to a third neuron
which we call a binding neuron
and what we find is the axonal delay
from here to here
is approximately equal to the delay from
here to here to here now this is much
easier to show in a powerpoint
presentation but i don't have that now
i'm hoping this will come across clearly
but we see these circuits of three
neurons
so lower feature higher feature binding
neuron
where the delay from the lower feature
neuron to the binding neuron is
approximately equal to the delay
from the lower feature neuron to the
higher feature neuron and then from the
higher feature neuron
to lower feature neuron so what happens
if that pattern of axonal delays emerges
through
learning which it does well then what
happens is that this binding unit if
we're in a rate great coded network
where we're not modeling the spike in
dynamics that binding neuron
would have the property the fire if it's
being driven by these two
being simultaneously active so these two
neurons are simultaneously active
they'll drive that third binding neuron
but that's of no interest whatsoever
that's just telling us these two are
corrected we're not interested in that
we want to know specifically is that
feature part of that feature
is that you're on driving that neuron
and only use it by
utilizing the spike in dynamics well
this neuron then is binding you and it's
third binding you and inherit the firing
property that it fires
if and only if this is actually driving
that
the spikes flow around that three new
and binding circuit to achieve that
so then that means that third binding
neurons comes to carry measurable
information about the binding
relationship between
those two features so in other words if
that low level feature was not
participating in driving the high level
feature maybe because the lower level
feature was part of a different
alphabetic letter
then the spikes from these two neurons
don't arrive at the same time
at the third and you want to make it
fire that's how it works
what you've described that sounds very
similar to capsule networks i'm not sure
if you've heard of that and
even though capsule networks don't use
spiking dynamics they have something
which is very similar to an attention
system or
a routing system which is where things
can be activated as a function of their
context or their pose
and even though it's in this substrate
of neural networks you can use it to
define quite complex compositional
relationships between
objects in a scene so i suppose i'm i'm
looking for
what do we get with it is it just a meat
space thing this
this spiking yes of course we've looked
at capsule networks and we've
um and it's a really interesting
question to try to compare capsule
networks with what's happening
in our spiking nets we're of the view
that what's happening in the spiky nets
is rather different
i know these are you know in some sense
they're trying to tackle rather similar
problems
but we think what's happening in the
spikey nets is rather different and i'd
be happy
i'd be very pleased to hear your point
of view on this when i've managed to
to to describe exactly what's happening
in the spiking nets
so what i've said is we have a feature
down here that itself may be invariant
in fact
in our simulations it often is and these
uh
and you asked me about in various
learning mechanisms spiking nets and
we've actually taken
the early work we did on weight coded
networks on these uh unsupervising
various learning mechanisms such as
continuous transformation learning trend
and trace learning and imported them
into a spiking network so to speak and
they operate perfectly well in a spiking
network
so those are unsupervised learning
mechanisms
will produce features at every spatial
scale in the hierarchy which displays
some kind of invariance maybe its
rotation in variance or
location events or scaling variants so
in our networks we see a hierarchy these
features emerging
through sensory experience where the
features themselves display a level of
invariance
and uh what i'm describing now how when
we have two features which uh
one is going to drive the other because
maybe this edge is part of that cup
or this bar is part of the t there's
going to be a third neuron
which will come to explicitly represent
that binding relation between the two in
other words that third neuron
will only fire if that feature is
specifically part of that feature
in the processing and not only that we
find much more complex binding circuits
emerging but then it gets very very
complex trying to analyze what's going
on
so it can get tremendously rich what i
should also say is
why that happens so i said we need that
specific pattern of axonal delays
obvious question is well how does that
emerge through self-organization let me
say a couple of things there
so we're implementing sort of quite a
standard form of what's called spike
time dependent plasticity
otherwise known as sddp and this is a
form of plasticity that operates at a
synapse
which is uh which will strengthen or
weaken that synaptic connection but it
it depends
critically on the relative timings of
the action potentials or spikes
from the pre and post-synaptic cells
from the sending and receiving cells
and specifically if the spike from this
the sending cell
arrives just before the spike from the
receiving cell
uh then we get ltp long-term
potentiation so the the synapse gets
strengthened
if it's the other way around if the
postsynaptic neuron fires first emits
the spike first then we get ltd
long-term depression so this is
so the connection gets weakened and very
interestingly this is very much in line
with the original apostle
donald hebb so we have something called
the hebrew in
uh in theoretical neuroscience which
simply
uh wires together neurons that fire
together now the heb rule is implemented
in weight coded networks and does not
take into account spike times because
rate code networks don't simulate spike
times it simply says
we strengthen the connection if two
neurons are active at the same time
that's not quite what donald hebb said
he said um he postulated that you would
get enhancement of the connection if the
presynaptic cell was participating in
driving the postsynaptic cell that's
much more specific
and that is it turns out that is
actually what you see in the brain
when you look at sddp so the sddp model
that we've implemented it will
strengthen the connection if during
learning the pre-synaptic cell is
actually participating in driving the
postsynaptic cell
and if it's not then it gets decremented
so
doesn't doesn't your paper i'm pretty
sure it made the point that
you know raven coding is probably at
least there's a lot of evidence just
from
timing the timing at which which our
brain can calculate things
that it's not feasible to do rate
encoding that there's just not even
enough time to really sample
the rate reliably there are probably
arguments to that effect but certainly
when you talk to the neurophysiologists
what they've observed
is a critical dependency on relative
spike times that's what's been observed
in the neurophysiology
no that that i buy but that's not so
much coding isn't it
that's really more what you're talking
about which is this delta this design
delta these are very different things so
the rate encoding like a hairball is a
very different beast
to spike to independent classicity which
we can only implement in a sparkling
network absolutely
and so that's what we found is that's a
critical part of the story so
with that with that sort of stdp i've
just described there are natural time
constants associated with it
and if you lengthen those time constants
so much that you lose a temple position
then you're back to sort of weight
coding sort of situation and then we
lose the emergence of
what we call polyconization or this rich
spatial temple structure so the http
does seem to be important
to that and so it takes a bit of
thinking about but if we implement that
kind of stdp i've just described
then you can see intuitively how we get
these three neuron binding circuits
emerging how that third binding neuron
will learn to respond to the current to
the
simultaneous arrival of two spikes from
the other two cells so you can just see
intuit it takes a bit of thinking about
you can see intuitively how that form of
sdtp
will promote the emergence of those
three neuron binding circuits and other
kinds of binding circuits more complex
forms
other simulations we run are for me more
interesting so actually when you look at
a real neuron you see a rich dendritic
tree
and the axon from the preset cell may
weave its way through that dendritic
tree making multiple synaptic contacts
where each of those synaptic contacts
contacts might have a different axonal
delay associated with it
and what we found is when we implement
this in our simulations the network is
able to preferentially
strengthen some synaptic connections and
not others according to the actual
delays and so
that's a way in which the axon delays
themselves can self-organize to promote
the emergence of the spatial temple
structure
uh which is a lovely result but beyond
that i think the most interesting thing
about all of this
is so where does all this spatial temple
structure come from but
well actually um so the original
simulations carried out by marcus
steezeman
he showed the emergence of synchrony
when the input spikes
were quite decorated they were quite
spread out in time
so he just saw over a series of layers
that gradual emergence of synchrony as
the the um the packet of spikes got more
and more narrow through time so you saw
the emergency synchrony
so in our simulations we also have
randomized spike times in the input
layer
and simply as they propagate up the up
successive layers
the polycry call it polyphony or
polychronization just emerges naturally
so all the spatial temple structure just
emerges naturally during learning
so you get something from nothing it's
very curious it's extraordinary really
this is this is really interesting we
were speaking with max welling a few
weeks ago and he is the
deep learning researcher most famous for
creating sophisticated inductive priors
in
deep neural networks uh to do things
like rotational invariants and
you know symmetries and different
manifolds and so on this bias variance
trade-off
it presupposes that in order for you to
learn in an efficient way you need to
encode
um some knowledge into the neural
network and it must be a similar thing
in in the brain but the way you're
describing this with this kind of
self-organized behavior
it sounds a little bit like you you
think of the brain as being a blank
slate yeah absolutely in terms of
self-organization absolutely
and that can be a problem in simulations
because it might not learn what you want
it to learn
but if i give you some examples of some
of the successes using this approach
so and most of our early work was using
rate coding models and rate coded mods
can still take you a long way even if
they don't solve binding
so one of the early problems we're
interested in is how the brain learns to
represent the
spatial structure of objects the shapes
of objects
another problem we've looked at is how
the brain learns to represent the
spatial structure of faces so when you
think about
recognizing faces and if i was to wind
back to my post-op days
we'd have a network and and we want to
train it on some uh
a face from one view and and hope they
could recognize that face from another
view
and by recognize we simply mean this
that the same output neurons end up
firing
so in other words it's just straight
categorization you know so we really do
when we think about recognizing an
object we think in terms of
categorization
but actually if i were to show you a
rotating cube you'd not only better
recognize that cube from different
angles but you'd see that cube you'd see
all the internal structure
the features of different spatial scales
and how they're related to each other
and that
is something that we don't tend to think
about so much now neurophysiologists
have actually
by recording from cells in the primate
brain are able to
been able to show that lots of neurons
to successive stages of visual
processing
encode shape primitives those primitives
might be
boundary contour elements so an
individual cell in areas such as
cortical area v4 uh would encode a local
boundary contour element where the cell
is sensitive to the conformation of that
boundary element so whether it's concave
convex and also the position with
respect to center of gravity of that
object
and then across the whole population of
these cells any sort of any any uh
two-dimensional 3d shape can be
encoded by subpopulation of those cells
we have a distributed representation of
shape
and so we've simulated that effect we've
trained one of our early networks
a hierarchy of layers using competitive
learning on lots of 2d object shapes and
we've seen the emergences exactly these
sorts of shape features that are seen in
the brain
and in analogous simulation studies
we've trained the same network
architecture on a couple of hundred
faces using software called face gen
which generates very realistic
um faces uh 3d faces we've trained the
network on a couple hundred randomly
generated
uh faces and we've seen the emergence of
a rich hierarchy of feature primitives
neurons encoding uh um feature premises
used to represent faces so
neurons encoding an eye and nose and
mouth
or or possibly the distance between the
eyes so
neurophysiologists have found a great
variety of cells which encode
geometric relations within the face
between features and all of these
geometric relations pop out of our
simulations they're just the network
just learns to
represent the same features that are
found by neurophysiologists in the brain
and not only that one of the most
interesting problems was that when you
look at someone
you can see their identity and you can
see their expression at the same time
and neurophysiologists have found
separate subpopulations of cells
encoding either facial identity or
facial expression
so how might they develop in the brain
since you always see these two
perceptual dimensions combined
in any face you look at and we just
simply exposed our networks our
unsupervised
self-organizing networks to hundreds of
faces and these sorts of cells which
which were responsive either to identity
irrespective of expression
or responsive to expression irrespective
of identity just popped out of the
simulations
and we do have a theoretical
understanding of how that works that's
really to do with these two spaces being
decorated and that forces
through competitive learning the neurons
to learn to go to individual perspective
individual perceptual spaces like
identity and expression
if i'm seeing a cube versus closing my
eyes
and and imagining that same cube is
there an overlap in the structures of my
brain that light up
and there is not exactly the same
experience is it but yes absolutely you
see the same sort of
structures in the visual brain light up
when you're when you're trying to
imagine
an object or a face right because what
i'm wondering about is
sort of you know the point that a lot of
like let's say the symbolic
oriented ai folks believe is that that
ability to
construct this representation if you
will in your mind
of that that object because when i
imagine it i can rotate it i can scale
it i can imagine
you know many of them together rotating
and scaling you know
that that may be an essential part of
this whole processing oh i think so
and indeed some of my colleagues at
oxford are working on working memory so
working memory is something that's
thought to take place in your prefrontal
cortex so after
layers of visual processing there'll be
a representation of some object in
working memory
but you know today the way you model the
way other people working memories they
use these
attractor networks but these are
typically rate coded attractor networks
well again you have this sort of
this population code which is just
represents the category of an object
for example now if you think about what
i've been saying about these spiking
networks these hierarchy layers which
are encoding features at every spatial
scale
and the binding relations in fact what
we're seeing in our simulations that i
haven't mentioned yet
is that the classic the classic way you
think about these networks is the output
layers are giving you the category of
object but what we're seeing in our
spiking networks
is evidence that features every spatial
scale including the hierarchical binding
relations are all being propagated up in
some form for readout
and that's extraordinary we call that
the holographic principle and that was
surely
um accord with you know the semantic
richness of our own visual experience
where when we look at the world we're
not just aware there's a cat but we see
the cat and all the features that make
up that cat
and surely that semantic richness of our
visual experience is important for
guiding
our behavior in the world and indeed
what would
underpin our our general intelligence so
this is probably a roadmap for the
future development artificial general
intelligence
if we come up to prefrontal cortex then
we think about attractors
what we hope to do in the future is is
extend our vision models into a
prefrontal cortex where we can model a
tractor dynamics
where within those um those spiking
attractor states
there'll be a rich array of information
about features of different spatial
scales and how they're bound together
to address the issue you've just raised
but that's in the future
so another interesting question is uh
we've been speaking with gary marcus
who's
quite a famous professor who criticizes
deep learning and
the the thing in the background with
deep learning is you will always have
folks that say
it's basically memorization professor
pedro domingos just last week i think
released a paper
likening neural networks to kernel
machines and what's interesting about
kernel machines is
that they are non-parametric methods
that basically learn
a kind of inner product space between
the data examples which means
it must be just interpolating between
the examples this notion of
representational learning might be kind
of exaggerated
but the the thing is gary marcus would
say that the the core problem
in these perception models is is the
kind of missing information problem
right we do reasoning let's say if if i
say the corner table wants a beer
we know that it's a person because that
information is missing but we've done
some reasoning over some world knowledge
and similarly i want to get to how do
you do this in variance in
scene understanding because as good as
the features learned are
you need to fill in the missing gaps
through some high level of reasoning
yeah let's let's pick up on that so you
know people talk about neural networks
generalizing
um i'm not sure about you know how
successful cnns are if you need to
train them on 10 000 images of a cat
before you can recognize a new cat
so we've actually to address your point
um in our biological models which are
unsupervised
in some of the simulation studies we
simply expose the early layers
to just random visual experience just to
build random feature analyzers
and because we have very different
learning mechanisms and i should also
say
that um with these unsupervised networks
the features which will
which the network learns we rather
different to the sorts of features
that a cnn might learn but using
these in various learning mechanisms i
described earlier what we find is those
features which get set up in the early
layers display some level of
transforming variance that can include
not just location events but also
scaling variance
and viewing various rotational variants
what that that when we've published all
this what that that then allows you to
do
is show one of these networks just one
shot view of an object a
three-dimensional object and then rotate
it
and it only needs one shot of you it's
happily it's happily
because you've what you've built is an
alphabet of visual spatial primitives
which themselves display transforming
variant by the same learning mechanisms
uh which can be used to encode any novel
object
which then you show that object in a
different viewpoint it will just the
same primitives are stimulated and it
will throw up the same output
representation
and so so in other words i began at the
beginning saying i suspected feature
binding is an important part of
achieving robust object recognition and
that means generalization
but i think there are other things going
on as well um like the the fact that
when it within one of these biological
unsupervised networks you form
a hierarchy of very different kinds of
visual spatial primitives which can
provide
an alphabet of primitives to encode
novel objects and then recognize those
objects from novel viewpoints
again all of this is backed up by the
newer physiology everything that comes
out of our simulations
has been seen in new physiological
studies
what you're saying essentially is that
the only reason neural networks don't
work is because they don't have a
sophisticated enough
compositional feature binding
relationship and in principle you think
that
um the brain does learn simple visual
primitives and
it has a very sophisticated
compositional mechanism to
give us that level of generalization
that is what you're saying yes i mean
there are multiple mechanisms at work if
you look at our research every 20 years
it's like one thing goes
on after the next everything builds on
what went before and
so what we what we're looking to do in
terms of next steps with these spiking
models
is to replicate some of the earlier rate
code studies on object shape
so so far we've looked at the emergence
of feature binding hierarchical feature
binding in spiking nets
now we want to start training on more
realistic problems maybe lots of phases
or two or three dimensional objects
and look at the emergence of this
hierarchy of features where the features
themselves
display transforming variants so that
they can be used to do one-shot learning
on novel objects
and indeed uh we've begun a
collaboration with imperial college
london to actually
carry out some of these simulations at
the moment i'm quite interested
in in these these kind of hierarchy of
features
from from your experience is it the case
that
there are if this is hierarchical there
are these low-level features
and is a certain low-level feature part
of
one or few or many high-level features
how does how does that all work do we
have sort of this kind of
alphabet that can compose into many many
words or
exactly that so and this is the
correspondence problem between the
layers
uh you know every time you present a new
image there'll be a different
relationship between the low and high
level features
that and that needs to be represented
explicitly so it can be used
that's that kind of binding information
can be used that's exactly right
can i just say we've talked a lot about
uh vision but there are other parts of
the brain which are
also interesting one area for example is
orchard processing of speech
and you've got you know similar sort of
architecture there and
um sort of a hierarchy of layers of
spiking neurons
and speech itself is a hierarchical
structure so
you know this this vowel would be part
of this phoneme part of this super
segmental part of this word and so on
and um so when we hear speech there's
all sorts of binding going on
as we're interpreting what we're hearing
including actually binding
speech to the identity of a speaker
who's currently talking to us
maybe interpreting their emotional
valence or
things like gender and age this is all
bound together
and so we've got our knowledge is
powerful binding problems in in in order
to pressing speech and that's one of the
areas we also want to look at
whether whether um you know we can
improve robustness to speech recognition
particularly against noisy rack grounds
using these sorts of spiking networks
and then the motor system the motor
system is again a hierarchy
of layers of spike in neurons where
neurophysiologists find
uh again you have motor primitives of
increasing spatial temporal scales two
successive layers
and there must be a knowledgeous feature
binding mechanisms
and then beyond that well we've actually
tried to build uh complete models of
brain function
by that i don't mean simulating 100
billion neurons but something that might
have risen in the canberran explosion
500 million years ago something quite
simple whether it's simple sensory but
maybe some simple photoreceptors
some simple output actuators and a layer
of neurons in the middle
that can learn to do some decision
making you can actually
see the simulations on our website so
we've built a system that's
the very very simple architecture that
can learn about causal relations in the
world
and we've dropped this into for example
two dimensional mazes is able to just by
moving around randomly
learn about the the uh the spatial
structure of the maze
so that later on uh you can put this
agent back in the maze
and it can navigate to any target
location in the maze
and the critical thing is if you change
the structure of that maze
it can then automatically you can learn
about the new say maybe you put a
blockage along a route so it can't take
that route
it can bump into it automatically learn
about it and then use its world
knowledge to take the next water through
and of course this was shown by edward
tolman in 1930s a famous psychologist
with rats
rats can do exactly this so rats even
the humble rat with the tiny brain can
learn about
causal relations in its world the
topology of its environment and use that
to go to guide behavior and that
is uh you might remember that the
original applications that brought deep
mind to fame were
learned to play atari computer games
using model 3 reinforcement learning and
so
you know back in 1930s edward thomas
showed the advantage of being the pavel
advantage of being able to learn and
model the world
to provide you with adaptable flexible
behavior in a changing environment
and so we're always driven by the
biology here but if we just focus on
that model a bit more
we've got a a visual system visual input
motor output
well in the brain these are hierarchies
of spiking neurons
all carrying out feature binding and so
we think that in the brain all this rich
information semantic information the
visual areas and the motor areas have
been projected up into
uh central areas like prefrontal cortex
where we learn about causal relations in
the world
and and that world knowledge we use to
guide our behavior but the critical
thing here is i'm going to suggest
in order in order for us to learn about
how the world works we need all that
rich semantic information
that is not just a hierarchy features
less scattered in space but also
information about how these features are
related to each other in order to be
able to understand our world
and learn those causal relations this
sounds
awesome you know it sounds like kind of
the the holy grail of you know what what
we've been trying to achieve for a long
time my question is um
if you could give us a survey on where
we stand as far as the state of the art
of training
uh these kinds of networks you know
because i believe at least
i think traditionally they've been much
more difficult to train
is that correct and how's that going
where do we stand now
uh are they practically useful okay yeah
so so the key thing is as i said at the
beginning
we always aim to build what we call
biologically realistic models
and um the sort of simulations we've
developed i'm sure there are other ways
you could approach it
but the reason it's important to build
biological models is because then as you
discover more about the new biology and
how it works you can incorporate that
as you go along and so now in a position
take those early behavior models and
incorporate the spike in dynamics and
that's indeed one of the next steps you
want to do
could i just gently challenge on that
you you say that it's advantageous to
model
let's say biologically um plausible
networks right so with spiking dynamics
aren't these dynamics uh relevant in the
substrate of biology
in the substrate of silicon why should
we try to model those dynamics so this
is my whole point about complex systems
because what we're ultimately interested
in is the emergent behavior of the whole
system
and my position is you only get that by
by simulating the dynamics right at the
lowest level and that means the
interaction between the neurons
so when you think about an upper cup you
don't just think of to pick up a cup
you're aware of that all the motor
primitives you use to pick up that cup
that's part of your experience and i
think it's also an important part of how
we learn
so i think those hierarchical binding
relations both in vision
audition other sensory areas and in the
motor systems is really important for
how our brain
learns to operate flexibly in the real
world to interpret it and to operate
flexibly
you said something fascinating when you
reference the uh the maze
solving behavior um now we've spoken to
kenneth stanley about this and he came
up with this concept called novelty
search
and we spoke to professor fristen uh
last week i'm sure
i'm sure you're aware of fristen's work
uh the free energy principle and that's
all about self-organized behavior
and what really differentiated fristan's
work is that you're getting away from
um this kind of goal direct you know
like in in reinforcement learning
systems you have a value function and
you need to have some kind of objective
and what you're describing here is some
kind of self-organized behavior where
you don't need to explicitly say what
good looks like it just kind of figures
it out by itself
do i understand that correctly well
actually when you're doing this
actually it's rather different to
reinforcement learning because when
you're doing the learning you don't need
a reward signal
you just learn about the environment you
learn about the dynamics the war comes
later on
uh which is rather interesting and much
more flexible i think but let me just
come back to that i think a deeper point
which is let's think about a mobile
robot today you know do we actually need
to go down this biological route
let's think about how a mobile robot
navigates around an environment today
well typically they just keep a record
of which parts of space are free of
obstacles
well that's not how i operate in a
complex environment i see features at
every spatial scale
and who knows how those features at
every spatial scale in their relations
is going to influence my intelligent
behavior but that's where it comes from
and i think we need that level of
semantic richness both in perception
and in action to be able to to behave in
a lifelike manner within real world
environments
that's my suspicion it's a postulate at
this point but it's what we're we're
this is our direction to travel so so
given your uh
mathematics background i wonder if i
could and this gets tim's question about
you know do we need
a particular feature uh you know i know
there's been a lot of
interesting work on the computational
capabilities
of different flavors of uh neural
networks and for example i think there
are some results that
if you have neurons that can have these
deltas these timing delays
that that puts them in a you know a
computationally more powerful uh
you know model at least in the sense
like let's say vc dimension or sontag
dimension or something like that
i'm wondering if you can talk to that a
little bit as to
how much power you gain by having the
ability to have these these
differential timings we're quite in an
early stage with respect to that
particular question so let me tell you
um about an issue we've had with some of
our weight coded networks which is the
closest thing to a convolutional network
so
what what i mean by a biological rate
coded network is is basically a series a
horrible series of competitive neural
networks
uh which is unsupervised so it's it's
it's so without the spike in dynamics
rate coded
and we've been developing a model called
viznet of the primary ventral visual
pathway for 20
years which is which is a hierarchal
rate coding model and
one of the problems we find is we lose
the stimulus specificity
um if we train uh for example
um an output unit on a letter t over all
positions on the retina
you think about how you compute the
activation of the output neuron it does
a sort of linear sum
over the inputs um and it's that means
that that tenure can become
subject to false stimuli where we can
actually
separate the elements of that t maybe a
horizontal vertical bar and we can
follow the system into thinking it's a
letter t
so there's a sort of lack of sensitivity
there
and but in a spiking network um
those elements will be represented by
these precise spatial temple chain
trains and so uh spatial temple trains
of spikes
and they have to arrive at the
post-synaptic cell uh simultaneously in
order to drive it so you actually need a
volley of spikes arriving simultaneously
at post-synaptics in order to drive it
and that can increase the specificity of
those neurons
but i make that as my team have seen
evidence of that in their simulations
but it's quite early for us so you can
see intuitively how
the temporal codes can offer greatest
specificity and power in in terms of
computation but we're quite
an early stage of of investigating that
i think we caught you off when you were
talking about adversarial
inputs to neural networks and this is i
mean this this relates to that
probably quite directly because what we
there are hypotheses about why these
adversarial inputs exist and mostly
they have to do with sort of decoupling
features so if i see a cat
there is the feature of you know the
general shape of the cat but there is
also the structure of the
fur and the whiskers and so on and these
are very tiny features
and what these adversarial examples do
in some
people's opinions is they they just take
these tiny features
that are not really visible to us humans
and they just crank them up
right so they'll they'll just put take
the whiskers feature and they just crank
it up with the first structure and just
crank it up
a lot and this never happens in nature
because
the large features and the small
features they're always correlated
but um in the adversarial example this
you know this can fool the network
if i understand you correctly if we
implement these these binding uh
complexes these three neuron complexes
then the third neuron it will only fire
if sort of the the whiskers
are part of the larger cat feature
right so if if the whisker if the
whisker struck or the first structure is
part of the actual fur and the fur
is part of the shape and so on and then
these neurons will will sort of encode
these things firing as a whole and
that's
why you yeah i think we caught yeah but
that's why you you
you probably went into this explaining
this could solve
one of these things there's a number of
things to mention there so one issue i'm
interested in is a problem called which
i call the picket fence
um if you see a cat on the other side of
the picket fence you can see these
different parts of the cat probably
belongs to the same cat
and um so the mechanism you've just
described is a way of solving that
problem
that at each layer in the hierarchy it
will decide which features belong to the
next feature up and so on and that will
go right the way up to the top
if we just come back to the prompt
adversarial noise one of my team has
actually tried to adapt to cnn
architecture
uh to incorporate these sorts of binding
neurons explicitly
and it can be done there are variety of
ways of doing it so to to adapt
a cnn architecture so it begins it
begins to start to preserve and utilize
exploit
uh information explicit information
about the higher relations between
features and he's
tested his network on black box
adversary attacks
and um i think on the mnist uh image set
he got
quite preferable performance over other
leading cnn architectures
but i probably shouldn't say too much
more because he's in the process of
submitting it for publication
but uh what i'd like to i'd like to add
to that is
um that won't bind you everything
primate vision can do because i i spoke
earlier about this
in these unsupervised networks you see
the emergence of this hierarchy of
visual shape primitives which are
themselves transform invariant
and that's probably part of the solution
and this is well known to
neurophysiologists who study the primary
visual system
you're talking here about similar to
capsule networks but more sophisticated
in my opinion
a kind of topology between features and
and how they
um how they kind of associate with each
other what about the partial information
domain you just said that you know the
cat is behind the picking fence
um how is your system robust to some of
those relationships not being seen
so and we haven't actually run that
simulation yet i should add um so that's
my my speculation in other words
you think about this the the way the
hierarchical binding works it's simply
if this neuron is driving that
urine there's another neuron which will
learn to represent that fact
so in other words these binding neurons
are representing causal relations
between features
wherever that could occur throughout the
brain in ways we haven't begun to think
about
um so you know you can imagine a
situation and it seems a bit trying to
talk about it since we haven't run the
simulations yet
where we've actually got cat features
being represented on two sides of a of
a picket fence and and they're driving
up and eventually you're stimulating a
cat
up here and but that cut up here is
being driven by the features on either
side of
a vertical bar you know we could imagine
a situation like that and not only that
when you think about people talk about
oh
where is cat where's the cat the cat is
nowhere what you what you see
is where the features are the cat is
just a kind of concept
what you see is the features and so and
so in the early visual stages those
feature neurons have small receptive
fields and so
those neurons not only carry information
about the feature but also where the
feature is in retinal space
and so if you imagine you've got a
binding urine telling you this feature
with a small receptor field is part of
that larger feature with a large
receptive field
that binding unit also um carries
information about the position of that
low-level feature within the within the
image and so all of that is getting
projected up
it seems like there also has to be some
top-down kind of generative
modeling you know like the free energy
principle that we talked about you know
last week
kind of shows that most likely we are
creating this generative model
of the world and constantly comparing
our predictions from that versus reality
and so when i see the cat behind the
fence i think it's a cat because in my
mind i have a model of a cat that if i
simulate
being behind the fence actually matches
what i would obser or what i'm observing
right now
even though i may have never seen a cat
fan so what we see in our simulations is
a huge attractor state so i'm talking
about hierarchical series of competitive
layers but actually you've got bottom-up
top-down lateral connections
and so that essentially forms a huge
attractor state
and where initially signals were and you
see this neurophysiologists report this
in the brain so for example
neurophysiologists recording from
neurons in area v2
cortical area v2 uh where you find
neurons that look a bit
like um simple cells so simple cells
will respond to edges and bars and so on
but what they see is initially a cell
responds like a simple cell
to an edge an edge in an image in its
field in its
um receptive field what happens then if
you wait a little while a few tens of
milliseconds the signals propagate up
and come back down
and then it modulates its response and
those neurons start to encode which side
of an object
that edge is and so what you've got is a
global attractor state across all the
layers
and of course we we throw that in our
spiking simulator yes so you've got that
kick down influence
i just want to add it as well as as well
as um the the future of models being
generative max welling said that
causality is super important as well so
he said that causality allows us to
easily transfer predictors from one
domain to the next
so accidents for example are correlated
with black cars in the netherlands
and perhaps with red cars in the us but
using color as a predictor doesn't
generalize very well but
if you had a causal factor such as male
testosterone levels
that will generalize very well indeed so
i think it's super important that we
introduce causality into these models
you're absolutely right how to do it is
another matter
you know there's all sorts of potential
high-level cognitions that could come
into visual interpretation
and it's that's nasty and you know we
try and take things one step at a time
so um what what are you you've spoken
about vision
and audio processing and you went quite
far up with audio processing and
generally in deep learning
these are really two separate fields
there is speech recognition which
is simply concerned with an audio signal
and then
resulting in text and then there is
natural language processing which
takes the text and and processes it into
whatever kind of
meaningful processing we do with
language sometimes called
natural language understanding what is
what is your view
on these do you think this is a
continuous sort of process in the brain
or is this like what are your views on
language
because the features you use to
interpret the auditory world
are the same features you use to
interpret language and again we approach
this using unsupervised competitive
learning
so actually one of the classic problems
in audition is how the brain learns to
represent pitch
and pitch isn't something extraordinary
because it's not the same thing as
frequency at all because you can
recognize a pitch if you you take out
even if you take out the fundamental
frequency you can hear the same pitch
and so how might that happen so in um
i think two or three years ago we
published a paper i think we're the
first people to do this where we had a
hierarchical
uh network i think it was a great code
at the time and uh we would just expose
it to lots of different
uh um they're called complex tones we
have a fundamental and all the higher
harmonics
and uh and then you can you can control
timbre by deciding which frequencies are
going to be present
you know that's why you hear a piano or
a violin we'll have you know this
dependent on the frequency on the actual
frequencies dependent
in the higher monarchs and we would we
would just expose the network to all
these different sounds natural sounds
musical instruments all sorts of things
and just through competitive learning
it would just learn to form a category
of pitch
and then it could it could recognize
pitch even if the fundamental frequency
was missing
i've always thought that's rather
similar to the problem of color
constancy and vision
where of course the colors we see aren't
real at all our brain just invents
colors
and it's similar sort of processing
which goes on but it's unsupervised
learning
i can see how that arises and
do you have any thoughts on the higher
up processing of language
so so once you sort of know what what's
being said
um how does how does meaning get in
there how do you derive
from an audio signal how do you actually
derive
what the other person wants to say yeah
and that's a very good question so far
we simply um
one of my former doctor students who's
now deep mind ran some simulations of
exposing a horrible spiking net to
language and
um and she found the emergence of these
three neuron binding circuits
and uh and what we call polychronisation
which is this rich temple spatial temple
structure spike trains
and she saw this just emerging naturally
in her in her simulations um
but that's as far as we've got um we
haven't gone we haven't gone beyond that
yet so so we take you know this
biological approach means tackling
these sort of low-level perceptual
problems before getting on to sort of
high-level stuff
the audio quite a bit funny you were
just talking about um a harmonic series
you know which is fascinating so uh
as you say the the harmonics are integer
multiples of the fundamental frequency
and even in the absence of the
fundamental frequency
we still um perceive that pitch and
there are other
things as well the mp3 algorithm is um
uh optimized to take advantage of lots
of perceptual oddities in
in in human auditory system right so our
cochlear
has these kind of weird critical bands
of hearing which are logarithmically
scaled and so on this kind of gets back
to my original point which is
isn't this stuff just hardware you know
humans we have a certain
set of hardware and it it it creates
this uh
perceptual mechanism i mean in the
critical bands of hearing that we have
for example one loud
sound will make it impossible for us to
detect a quieter sound in that critical
band and
i think a loud sound in time will make
it impossible for us to hear another
sound directly afterwards and so on so
isn't that just our hardware
yeah this is a really good point because
it's about what it is ultimately is
is dynamics that's what it is it's about
dynamics whether that's realized in
you know whatever form of hardware
you're using whether it's silicon or
carbon
it's about dynamics and dynamical
behavior so i mentioned earlier that
one of my former lab members had had run
simulations exposing a horrible spiking
network to
just natural language and saw the
emergence of features like vowels and
phonemes and words
uh where there were hierarchical binding
relations neurons encoding hardcore
binding relations between those features
and because she was implementing this in
a spiking net
i don't care how you do it whether you
do it on the gpu or in the brain it's
the dynamics which are important to the
to the
to the to the very nature of the sensory
representations
which emerge it's the qualitative nature
of those sensory representations which
are critical
if we could go back to using biology as
inspiration for maybe
features that or signpost as you put it
for features that could be very useful
uh in building intelligent systems
there's this kind of hierarchy that some
people say you know the first generation
neural networks were those that were
discrete like the old perceptrons
second generation were continuous and
had weighted sums
and non-linear activation functions
third generation are these kind that
you're talking about that have the
ability to have
timings you know spike timings and
whatnot is
is actual functional pieces of the
neural network if you had to guess what
fourth generation would be
what would it be so what what features
are we missing of
actual neurons and or biological uh
networks of neurons that we we need to
bring in
next to further increase our capability
let me give you an answer to that but
perhaps not quite the answer you're
anticipating
let's think about spatial navigation
there's a very basic task
now you're asking me about the
architecture and the dynamics of the
euros themselves
as i said today's mobile robots they
might simply record
which parts of an environment are free
of obstacles when you talk to
neurophysiologists
what they'll tell you is they'll tell
you about neurons in and found in the
rat brain monkey brain
that encode the position of an animal
within its environment and the structure
of that spatial environment
well-known classes of cells include
place cells anirats
early 1970s found in the hippocampus of
rats which fire whenever the animal's in
a particular place in its environment so
a population of cells like that will
encode where the animal is
about a decade later uh head direction
cells were
found and these cells encode the current
heading um
of the animal whether it's a rat or a
primate
so those are two different kinds of
spatial representations and we've been
modeling those
the emergence of those representations
so we've built um we've got to the stage
now where we can build build a
completely self-organizing system
which we can drop into any sort of
spatial environment it will just explore
that spatial environment and these cells
will emerge in a completely
uh unsupervised self-organizing man and
it took us about 15 years to get to that
point
um probably take us less time if we have
more funding
but the really critical thing is that
neurophysiologists report that actually
these cells that have been reported are
just the simplest kind of cells
um you know you see a cell which
responds whenever the animal's in the
place and you think my god
that's such a simple clean story that's
like nobel prize time for that
but there are lots of other cells that
neurophysiologists observe more abs with
a more abstract firing properties that
are clearly encoding
spatial information about the world but
more much more difficult to interpret
what
what kind of information what role
they're playing yet all these cells are
part of a rich tapestry of spatial
representations which work together
to support spatial navigation spatial
processing and navigation
and that's where we're headed as a lab
to try to build these these large scale
simulations from sensory input to motor
output where and
if you're interested the critical thing
that allowed us to get these simulation
to work was including not only the
visual input which other people have
been doing but it turns out
we all know the brain has neurons
encoding self-motion
like rotation of the head and forward
velocity um
so we actually included what these what
are called idiotic signals self-motion
signals into the simulations
and they turn out to be critically
important for determining for actually
guiding
the emergence of these kinds of
interesting cell properties and so for
example as an example
we found that um head direction cells
emerge in these simulations
when we include not only the visual
input but also information from
head rotation cells these are called
angular head velocity cells so if you
include an angular head velocity input
that drives emergence of head with
head direction cells but if you replace
the angle head velocity with a
combination of forward velocity
and head direction you see the emergency
place cells so um
and because we sort of crack that
problem now we know these internal
motion signals are really important to
the self-organization of these
spatial representations now we can go on
to develop the simulated agents where we
can look at a
whole variety of different kinds of
spatial representations which emerge and
try to understand the nature of those
representations within simulations
and understand how they weave together
to support robust navigation that's
one of the things we want to do going
forwards and so so i haven't really
asked your question because i'm what i'm
saying is there's so much still to
discover with the
current generation of neural networks
that i'm not really thinking about the
next stages
how do you know right because
neuroscience is an order of magnitude
harder than the kind of stuff we do of
artificial neural networks but
with your new type of of computational
architecture that you're describing
just to contrast i mean in the world of
neural networks we have all of these
weird and wonderful ways of reasoning
about their behavior right we things
like
counter factual examples and data
grouping and we even solve a weird
optimization problem to kind of go the
other way through the network to
you know give us some idea of feature
visualization or something what kind of
approaches are you using to make these
statements about the behavior of your
models yeah
it is it is it is difficult in fact it's
damn difficult it really is to try and
check out what's going on i'll tell you
what the
one of the reasons is so difficult is
because um what i've been talking about
are
polychronous mineral groups this is a is
a subpopulation of cells
which are encoding a particular feature
whatever that feature is
and they encode that feature with a
particular temple pattern of spikes so
this neuron fires that neuron fires and
so on like this
and they can be very rich and complex
but the real headache
is that an individual neuron could
participate in hundreds of these pngs
simultaneously so you could have a
hundred of these polynomial groups all
sitting on top of each other
with different periods it looks just
like an absolute mess
and i work with oxford
neurophysiologists trying to come up
with ways of actually you know but
they're recording from say 100 neurons
in the visual cortex out of maybe i
don't know 10 or 20 billion
and they're trying to how can we
actually you know even identify the
existence of these pngs because if you
know
you record it from say 10 cells and
you've and they're all participating in
hundreds of pngs it just looks like
where's the structure how are you going
to pull out the
keys out the structure from that and and
the same applies to our simulations
there are techniques for searching for
extracting
pngs independent pngs but it really is
difficult and that's why
you know so far sort of focused on this
three neuron binding circuit because
we could pin that down and we could look
at the axonal delays and saw that the
actual delays were exactly what we
predicted
in in terms of their relations in order
to achieve that binding effect
but really going beyond that and of
course um you know i've talked about
this neuron encoding relationship
between
these two neurons but this neuron can
code all sorts of complex relationships
on multiple levels
it's an absolute and indeed it may not
be a neuron that's encoding that it
could be a sub-population cells encoding
it
using a png encoding it just goes on
forever
it's honestly i almost felt like
retiring i looked at this complexity
i feel it's something for the next
generation i'm very happy i wonder what
what would you say to the folks who say
you know what uh don't worry
actually you don't need to worry about
all that that complexity because uh hey
we don't even need all these um
you know timing timing capabilities and
whatnot we just need
gpt because right now you know sure it
only has 10 to the 11th uh
neurons but by the time we get to gpt5
it'll have 10 to the 15th
and you know maybe the next version
after that we'll have plenty of neurons
to do
all the calculation we need you know
from this very simple substrate
so here's my instinct i was watching an
interview with rodney brooks
a few years back and of course well
known for the cog project i believe at
mit
so the humor robot the media loved it
because they could take photographs
and in early work i hear them talking
about this cod project saying yeah well
next week we're going to
we're going to we're going to add in an
extra subroutine so it can track you
with its eyes around the room and a week
after that we'll do something else
and you know i think a lot of people
listening to that would have a degree of
skepticism about
you know how far that approach is going
to get where you're sort of trying to
layer on these additional cognitive
capabilities in a step-by-step fashion
and i remembered maybe two or three
years back watching an interview with
rodney but we just sat there saying i've
just come to the view after all these
years that there's something missing
there's just something missing in this
and i felt the same thing as a postdoc
looking at our model
business something missing and i think
these hierarchical binding relations
i've talked about you think about a
classic cnn or one of our early rate
coded networks
you've got a rich hierarchy of visual
primitives but there's no information
about
their relations and that's just one
example of something fundamental it's
missing in terms of information
processing so it's the information
processing which is important
and that depends on the neuronal
dynamics we've got to get that right
we've got to get the
neuronal dynamics right so during
self-organization as this thing is
exposed to the sensory world
we get the right kinds of
representations emerging the network
representations and we've not begun to
think about yet
we're on the very first steps with this
feature binding idea
you know and i this is why i take this
complex systems approach and i try to
follow the biology and see where it
takes us and um
and that's why i feel in the longer term
this is the right way to go incidentally
i
i don't know whether i mentioned it yet
but psychologists and philosophers have
long regarded feature binding is the
newer foundation of consciousness itself
in the brain
and i think that's that that's that's
the right way of thinking about it
and certainly i would regard feature
binding as a necessary
platform for the future development
office of general intelligence i think
we're going to build systems that can
make sense of the world
and behave flexibly within real world
environments we're going to need
uh to solve feature binding in a really
effective way and have all that
information projected up
as i said the phrase i use is a
semantically complete representation of
the world because when you look at a
visual theme
you can interpret what's happening in
every spatial scanner i'm sure that's
important for
uh uh uh supporting flexible behavior in
real world environments
i think that the feature binding is
absolutely fascinating but i want to
just take a step back to what you said
at the beginning because you said
before you got to the feature binding
you made a lot of uh headway on
continuous transformation learning and
trace learning and and those were
absolutely critical for
you know for learning these
representations so could you could you
just fill in that gap as well yeah sure
so we're sort of doing this in reverse
but this is uh you know one of the very
early problems i worked on so the
challenge here is
is uh it's not just to get a network to
recognize an object from different
viewpoints is
how can we get how could this happen
within a biologically realistic network
well we can't tell the network what it's
looking at on any occasion
and we're also allowed we're constrained
in the kind of learning rules we use
um so there should be local rules that
means the information you use to adapt
to synaptic connection
is has to be locally available so in
other words something like the firing
rates of the pre and post-melodic cells
of the synapse
is used to modify that synapse so those
are like if you like the rules of the
game
as i said they're not really wars
they're signposts but anyway that was an
early problem we worked on
and um so continuous transformation
learning is
is uh well actually trace learning was
was proposed first
by i think it's a chap called peter
foldiac
and the idea is the idea of both these
mechanisms is that they exploit
the natural statistics of the visual
world so for example
um you've just been sat looking at me
for about an hour and 15 minutes
and uh and and so all these different
views of my face have been clustered
together in time
so there's temporal continuity could the
visual system exploit that kind of
temporal continuity
um and indeed trace learning does
exactly that so if you take a standard
hebrew
and you replace either pre-synaptic fire
rate or the post-synaptic fine rate
with a a memory trace just something
reflecting recent activity
the system will automatically um it will
form neurons which learn to go to infra
patterns which tend to occur
uh close together in time and if we
assume in the visual world different
transforms of an object tend to occur
closer together time
then such a network can learn
transforming variants
of course it runs into problems if
you're actually circadian rapidly around
the scene and you're mixing up
uh different objects the system can get
confused so that's a limitation of that
kind of learning
and then later came continuous
transformation learning which is
something i proposed
which uses spatial similarity so all the
different transforms you've seen of me
as i
rotate my head form a continuum of
rather similar
images and one of these sorts of
biological networks can actually exploit
that continuity
to form output neurons which can respond
to that whole continuum
and so these are two two local learning
mechanisms which operate very
effectively to develop
invariant representations and these
invariant representations can emerge at
every level in the hierarchy
so this is what we see we see neurons in
the early layers which are which are
learned to encode elemental features
uh develop some degree of transforming
variance and that means
later on if we share a novel object they
can be encoded by the same alphabetic
primitives where because those
parameters are transforming variant
the thing can then carry out one shot
object recognition
what what category exactly of invariance
are they learning is it
affine invariants or something else it
could be anything because just think
about it
um the way these mechanisms work is
they'll just associate together images
which either
occur close together in time in the case
of trace learning or are rather similar
to each other they form a sort of
continuum of
rather similar images so they can learn
rotation and variance scaling variance
um viewing variance any sort of
invariance you you might
care to think of can they also learn
sort of warped you know warping
invariants or strokes
we taught it that but of course what
they key off is what they see in the
natural world
so if a certain kind of invariance is
not really very natural they're not
going to learn it because they have to
be exposed to that kind of invariance
but do i understand correctly that
you're almost transforming it into a
kind of non-geometric problem so you
kind of get that for free
yes yeah that's it isn't it yeah
absolutely
absolutely and it's biologically
plausible and we've
we've gone on to replicate those
learning mechanisms in spiky nets
i was gonna take a step back and you
talk a lot about
biological plausibility but you mainly
run these
sort of simulations could you just talk
to us
how do you work together with biologists
to make sure that
what you're doing is biologically
plausible
and to translate your findings into what
it means for the brain and so on how
does your work look
like you know in conjunction with these
people
because we're building new network
models i think the primary experimental
data we're interested in
is what we call single or multi-unit
recording this is where a
neurophysiologist puts
an electrode or an array of electrodes
into part of an animal's brain
and records how those cells are firing
as an animal undertakes a task which
might be just
looking at images on the screen or it
might be wandering through a spatial
environment
so i used to work with
neurophysiologists at oxford
who were carrying out experiments on
macaques
and so in one study for example they
would have a core from an area known as
hippocampus as the animal wandered
around its room
and at oxford they discover what are
called spatial view cells in the macaque
brain
um these are cells that fire whenever
the animal's looking at a particular
part of the room
and uh and then so we would we would
characterize the firing properties of
those cells
and then we think about how can we build
a simulation
to show how those cells could emerge let
me give you another example and i like
to tease my undergraduates with this
example
some neurophysiologists have found
neurons that encode
the position of an object a visual
object
not with respect to the retina but with
respect to a part
another part of the body such as the
head or the hand
so for example is my pen and you see
this configuration like this here's my
hand here's the pen
and you'll find a neuron in the macaque
brain which will respond to that
configuration where that pen
has is in this position with respect to
the hand and that same neuron will fire
wherever you show those on the retina
but if i move the pen to a different
position with respect to the hand
and then a different cell will fire so
these cells are encoding the positions
of object
in different body centered frames of
reference where that body center frame
reference might be the hand or the head
and my lab has when i first read about
those cells
there's no there's no idea of how they
could develop those cells have thought
to be very important though
you know encoding the position of an
object with respect to the hand
uh explicitly is thought to underpin our
ability to reach out and grab an object
okay so those are important classes of
cells
and no one ever when that when these
cells were discovered no one ever said
here's how we think they develop
well how do they develop there's an
eating question for a theoretician
and uh it didn't immediately occur to me
how to solve that problem i thought
that's a very interesting class of cell
i've seen other classes of cells which i
didn't know how to solve immediately
but in this particular case let's and
i've given you enough information to
solve it already how do you how would
you solve that
well did you mean to solve the
development problem
exactly how would you build a
biologically plausible model from what i
said so far in this interview
to solve that problem how would you
build a model that can in which these
kinds of hand-centered neurons could
emerge
through some sort of self-organizational
learning process are you okay if we use
python
but just come up with come on a
theoretical suggestion this is what we
do
you've asked me your auditions this is
what we do i suppose you need some sort
of a
a experience lots of experience of
grabbing things right like of of the
viewpoint of an animal
as it grabs things or reaches for things
and then the the success or failure of
the grabbing will sort of be dependent
on
where objects are with respect to the
hand
right so um i don't know how to do it
without a reward signal but i guess with
a reward signal of actually
successfully or not successfully
grabbing something
the feature of where something is in
relation to the hand
would be some kind of a natural emergent
thing
i'm thinking maybe maybe i would need
data about the direction that my eyes
are looking
in the direction that my hand is
oriented
and looking for uh you know synchronous
kind of alignment
of those of those variables or inputs
people assume you know we talk about
humans as having extreme generalization
that's not really the case we can't
recognize faces upside down and
there's actually a very kind of
heliocentric and anthropocentric
um skew to a lot of our cognition we're
really really bad at
anything in 4d for example and the
travelling salesman problem we can't
really
do that beyond about 20 cities so people
exaggerate that notion
okay let me let me put you out of your
misery because it's important point this
is what we do to theoreticians
we try to solve problems like that and
if i put that problem to a
neurophysiologist
they wouldn't be able to answer it and
and disappointingly sometimes my
students can't answer eve
answer it even even after they've taken
my undergraduate program in
computational neuroscience
so if we think about the learning
mechanisms i just described to you trace
learning and ct learning
and you think about what might happen
ecologically an animal might have you
know an object with a certain position
with respect to the hand
but all the time you're circading around
the place the whole time you all the
time you've got microcase and
larger circades and what that will
result in is lots of images lots of
different images
of that hand object configuration being
fed into your
into your brain your visual brain all
clustered close together in time
and so we simply run a simulation where
the animal is simply looking around the
place and you can do this with multiple
objects and then it i won't go into the
details of that but it can do
you can use you can put a hand against a
natural background it still works
if you employ either trace laying or ct
learning where
in trace learning you can but you a
neuron will learn to respond to images
which occur close together in time
in ct learning the the the neurons will
learn to respond to images which are
similar to each other that's enough if
you just expose it
to to you you train it on on a visual
input stream as an animal just circadian
round environment
with its hand steady against the
background or with another object
present
those hand-centered neurons
automatically develop as a property of
transforming variance learning
people have written hold books on on on
circade behavior and fixation
um in the microsuitcase you actually you
just do that subconsciously all the time
anyway
um if you stabilize an image on the
retina you'll go blind eventually so you
your visual system needs to perform
micro circuits all the time
and then um larger circades they can be
driven by all sorts of processes you
might you might um
they could bottom up processes or top
down processes if someone important
walks into a room
you automatically tend to look at them
but also other things like primitive uh
visual elements can cause you to pay
attention to one part of the visual
scene so we're circadian all the time
you know a number of cicadas every
second and so the assumption then in the
simulation is that you're performing
circades more rapidly than you're moving
your hand
and that's you know so so in other words
the hand is is relatively steady against
a background while you're circling
around the place that will result in a
series of images
of that particular hand object
configuration different positions on
your retina and they'll get bound
together by either trace lane or ct
learning and that will create a hand
centered neuron
so frames per second matter i always i
always knew i should aim for higher fps
and uh
in video games now i know why dr simon
stringer thank you so much for joining
us it's been an absolute honour
i've really enjoyed this conversation
with you today
thank you so much it's been my pleasure
it really has thank you
thank you bye-bye